[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24 son
487 los funcionarios del gobierno
peruano que fueron vacunados de manera
secreta contra el copy 19 dentro del
escándalo conocido ya como el vacuna
gate que ha llevado a la renuncia de las
ministras de salud y de relaciones
exteriores así como a señalamientos
contra el ex presidente martín vizcarra
analizamos el tema en minutos
los diputados de la asamblea nacional de
francia votarán hoy el proyecto de ley
con el que buscan fortalecer el laicismo
francés y combatir el yihadismo la
propuesta fue hecha por el presidente
manuel marco tras el asesinato de un
profesor que exhibió caricaturas del
profeta mahoma en una clase sobre
libertad de expresión en minutos también
conectaremos con parís para más detalles
nueva jornada de manifestaciones
ciudadanas en jean marc en rechazo al
golpe de estado del primero de febrero
la junta militar negó haber perpetrado
un quiebre de la democracia y presentó
nuevos cargos contra la líder de puesta
aún sanssouci quien permanece arrestada
muy buenos días américa latina'
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález vamos a
comenzar en perú en américa del sur en
donde se siguen dando a conocer más
detalles sobre el escándalo relacionado
con la vacunación anticipada de
funcionarios públicos en una trama que
ya es conocida como el vacuna gates
recientemente fue dado a conocer que son
487 personas que se aprovecharon de sus
cargos públicos para recibir de manera
secreta las dosis de la vacuna china
scinopharm contra el kobe 19 las
denuncias ya han llevado a la renuncia
de dos ministras y también a
señalamientos contra el ex presidente
martín vizcarra el actual mandatario
francisco sagasti rechazó la actuación
de los funcionarios y también pidió
avances en la investigación
alva santana tiene los detalles la
ilusión por la llegada de las vacunas a
perú duró poco tras que el presidente
interino francisco sagasti anunciara el
domingo que un total de 487 personas
entre ellas funcionarios públicos se
vacunaron en secreto aprovechando una
partida complementaria de scinopharm el
mandatario condenó los hechos y aseguró
que los responsables serán investigados
y apartados del ejecutivo por nuestra
parte desde el ejecutivo separaremos a
todas las personas involucradas en este
lamentable suceso personas que no son
capaces de cumplir cabalmente su deber
como servidores públicos no tienen
cabida en este gobierno el escándalo
comenzó el jueves cuando se destapó que
el expresidente martín vizcarra había
recibido la vacuna en octubre
vizcarra aseguró que había sido
voluntario de un ensayo clínico aunque
la fiscalía y la población tienen dudas
al respecto la controversia también
llegó hasta el actual gobierno de
sagasti con figuras como la ex ministra
de exteriores elizabeth act quien
renunció tras reconocer haber sido
vacunada y la ex ministra de salud pilar
mazzetti involucradas
la lista que presentó sagasti también
figuran los nombres de otros cargos
públicos el caso conocido como vacuna
que llega en plena segunda ola de la
pandemia haya causado indignación entre
los peruanos es un tema creo que más
ético no no no puedes
tu binocular de y tu familia y algunos
pocos funcionarios cuando hay gente en
la primera línea de doctores que se han
muerto
sagasti y nombró a allan wagner como un
nuevo ministro de exteriores en un
intento por recomponer su gabinete
mientras los peruanos se enfrentan a una
crisis de confianza política a la par
que la pandemia y de cara a las
elecciones presidenciales de abril
analizamos este tema saludamos a elena
al vitesse analista y docente de derecho
constitucional de la pontificia
universidad católica del perú muy buenos
días para usted señora al vitesse y en
un país tan golpeado políticamente como
lo está pero este nuevo escándalo como
impacta entonces en la credibilidad del
estado y de los propios funcionarios
peruanos
buenos días santi y buenos dias santiago
si este escándalo impacta negativamente
en el devenir del perú y particularmente
en lo que es la gestión creo que ha
buscado ser siempre transparente del
gobierno de transición y emergencia que
tenemos desde noviembre del año pasado
no los los entretelones de la
investigación el ensayo clínico todavía
van a ser develados e investigados con
una comisión multisectorial pero sin
duda en la ciudadanía en la población y
creo que entre la mayoría de analistas
tenemos la sensación de que se ha
aprovechado el cargo de funcionarios
públicos desde el más alto funcionario
público para recibir esta inicialmente
en septiembre el candidata de vacuna y
ya a partir de diciembre como vacuna no
señor al vitesse en el marco legal
peruano a qué tipo de sanciones estarían
enfrentando entonces estos funcionarios
que han sido acusados o han sido
señalados dentro de este escándalo
bueno los funcionarios a nivel
ministerial en este caso serían dos
estamos frente a tres posibilidades no
es decir la sanción administrativa en
línea de carrera por ejemplo en el caso
de la ex canciller no pero también como
ministra está sujeto en términos
constitucionales al antejuicio
constitucional que supone un
procedimiento entre congreso de la
república y la posibilidad de una
sanción de inhábiles de inhabilitación
hasta por diez años de igual modo esto
es parte de investigación que ya se
inició en el ministerio público
cualquier delito de corrupción o
aprovechamiento ilícito a nivel penal
por el cargo
y esto mismo a la ex ministra de salud
no en el caso del personal
administrativo que no tiene que no es
alto funcionario pues todo lo que
corresponde al ámbito de disciplinario
administrativo y penal
elena al vitesse en la ciudad de lima la
capital de perú muchas gracias por
explicar a este tema la teleaudiencia de
france 24 avanzamos con otros temas
del día en francia- esta tarde a la hora
local se espera que sea votada por los
diputados de la asamblea nacional la ley
de separatismo propuesta por el
ejecutivo el proyecto tiene por objetivo
actuar de manera drástica contra el
yihadismo y fortalecer el laicismo
francés la propuesta fue hecha por el
propio presidente manuel marco en
octubre pasado después de que un
profesor fuera decapitado por mostrar
caricaturas del profeta mahoma en una de
sus clases cuyo tema era la libertad de
expresión vamos a conocer más detalles
en natalia ruiz en parís la capital
francesa natalia cómo va a desarrollarse
entonces esta jornada y que tanto apoyo
puede recibir este proyecto de ley entre
los diferentes partidos allí en la
asamblea nacional tiene posibilidad
entonces de ser aprobado
muy buenos días pues espera que la
sesión comience dentro de unas pocas
horas y el voto cede sobre finales de la
tarde de este martes aquí en parís es un
texto que ha dividido muchísimo al
parlamento ya se sabe por ejemplo que el
partido socialista va a abstenerse de
votar que 'francia insumisa para su
partido de izquierda y también
reagrupación nacional de extrema derecha
votarán en contra pero es muy posible
que el texto finalmente sea aprobado ya
que la mayoría va a votar a favor la
verdad quienes se oponen a este texto de
ley han dicho que finalmente es un texto
que no aporta ningún tipo de solución a
los problemas precisamente para que
sigan proliferando este tipo de
discursos que separan a la nación pero
lo más probable es que ese texto sea
aprobado y luego pasará ya a voto en el
senado en el mes de marzo
natalia usted lo menciona hay divisiones
al interior de la asamblea pero también
en la sociedad francesa que es lo que
contempla entonces este proyecto de ley
que ha generado rechazo por algunos
sectores como los defensores de las
libertades individuales y también de los
derechos humanos hay mucha polémica allí
así es hay unos artículos bastante
controvertidos el primero de ellos es el
que más el debate de género debate
bastante intenso fue en torno a la
educación en casa algo que de manuel
mccone quería prohibir pero el
parlamento no siguió por esta línea a
pesar de que era una manera según el
presidente de que se pudieran evitar la
proliferación de más escuelas digamos
que en las que haya discursos radicales
en todo caso la puerta sigue abierta
para ese tipo de educación pero tendrán
que tener el aval del ministerio de
educación nacional y algunas de
erogaciones como por ejemplo prácticas
culturales artísticas o motivos de salud
o otro de los puntos allí a la creación
de un nuevo delito cuando se difunda
informaciones personales de una persona
y que esto ponga en riesgo la vida de la
persona estas digamos para luchar contra
el odio en internet se ha creado este
delito 45 mil euros de multa tres hasta
tres años de cárcel y el último es uno
de los puntos más álgidos qué tiene que
ver con la regulación de las
asociaciones de culto la mayoría de las
iglesias de las mezquitas las
congregaciones funcionan
este bajo esta figura y lo que quiere el
estado finalmente se controlará aún más
la financiación de estos de estas
asociaciones quienes están detrás de
estas asociaciones sobre todo cuando
piden a de subsidios a por parte del
estado en realidad los representantes de
los diferentes cultos aquí en el país
han dicho que creen que es una ley
demasiado represiva e incluso puede
tener efectos son contraproducentes
mucha controversia allí en francia
gracias natalia por este reporte y
atentos a el desarrollo de esta votación
importante allí en la asamblea nacional
en francia
seguimos en europa en españa la pandemia
el confinamiento y también la
incertidumbre ha llevado a un incremento
en el número de solicitudes de divorcio
muchos de los ciudadanos españoles han
optado por recurrir a las llamadas
divorcio netas que es un instrumento
creado por un despacho de abogados que
busca agilizar el trámite de divorcio
pero a muy bajo costo veamos la historia
es imposible no ver esa camioneta por
las calles de madrid sus llamativos
carteles rosas promocionan una oferta
peculiar un divorcio por sólo 150 euros
el abogado alberto garcía cebrián ha
inventado este vehículo le bautizamos
como el nombre de divorcio neta como
algo comercial como un marketing que
pretende dar cercanía a algo tan lejano
como el divorcio con sus divorcio netas
el abogado quiere romper el tabú del
divorcio unos de nuestros lemas es
juntos o separados pero felices estamos
acostumbrando a la gente a que el
divorcio no se vea como un drama sino
simplemente una decisión una opción que
puede poner una solución una familia
esta manera de pensar convenció a javier
conocía a su mujer desde más de 20 años
y decidió dar el paso
digamos menos y el confinamiento que ha
provocado que estén mucho tiempo juntos
y ahí tomar la decisión pues que os
hemos arreglado más el negocio del
divorcio a bajo costo nunca había tenido
tanto éxito por el primer confinamiento
vino una avalancha de divorcios y lo que
decían era que querían divorciarse
rápido urgentemente para que si venía
otro confinamiento no le pillará con la
misma compañía en el tercer trimestre
del 2020 justo después del primer
confinamiento hubo entre un 15 y 20 por
ciento más divorcios que los años
anteriores
para alberto es una tendencia que
seguirá creciendo muchas gracias
para este psicólogo el fenómeno apenas
acaba de empezar se han separado todavía
pues porque no les ha dado tiempo acudir
a los juzgados o no tienen dinero para
una separación por una separación es
cara
y se han tenido que quedar sobre el
papel dentro de su relación pero
emocionalmente están las parejas rotas
otra consecuencia del confinamiento el
número de bodas se han desplomado porque
han sido aplazadas 2020 podría ser el
primer año con un número mayor de
divorcios que matrimonios en españa sólo
150 euros cambiamos de tema nos vamos
hasta mianmar miles de personas
volvieron a salir a las calles de las
principales ciudades de ese país para
rechazar el golpe militar del pasado
primero de febrero al día de hoy la
junta militar que tomó el poder ha
restringido numerosos derechos y ya es
la segunda noche consecutiva en ese país
en el que se mantiene suspendido el
acceso al servicio de internet los
militares aseguraron que seguirán en el
poder hasta las próximas elecciones y
también negaron haber cometido cualquier
tipo de golpe de estado de otra parte la
líder de puesta a un sandwich y continúa
arrestada al tiempo que le han imputado
nuevos cargos en su contra
álvaro cordero nos cuenta más
la situación política en mianmar parece
estar lejos de solucionarse luego de dos
semanas del golpe militar miles de
ciudadanos siguen saliendo a las calles
para exigir la vuelta de la democracia y
desafían al poder del ejército
quiero que más gente se una a las
protestas no queremos que nos vean
débiles
nosotros los estudiantes tenemos nuestro
futuro tenemos que resistir para no
vivir bajo una dictadura militar
la junta ha negado que su acción del
pasado 1 de febrero sea un golpe de
estado y se ha comprometido a devolver
el poder una vez se realicen nuevas
elecciones sin embargo la socavación de
derechos democráticos fundamentales ha
sido constante en estas semanas durante
las últimas dos noches que internet fue
cortado para los ciudadanos y se han
hecho con el control de los bancos
imponiendo este martes un límite de
retiro que ha generado caos entre muchos
birmanos a esto se suman las numerosas
detenciones
h
entenderíamos una represión si fuéramos
violentos
ahora no podemos aceptar una represión
por estar protestando pacíficamente
los principales líderes políticos entre
los que está aún sang soo choo siguen
arrestados de hecho el abogado de la
lideresa birmana aseguró que los
militares le acusaron con un nuevo cargo
que es la violación del artículo 25
utilizado para enjuiciar a aquellos que
no cumplen con las restricciones a causa
del coronavirus esto podría detener
indefinidamente su juicio y llevarla a
prisión por hasta tres años
punto final en las noticias de france 24
más información en france 24 punto com
en las redes sociales y en la app buenos
días para todos
[Música]